fait regarder quelqu'un avec nous
l'auteur c'est delphine way
roger et rogers et oui le beau gosse le
playboy qui est un champion de ping pong
je savais pas qui joue extrêmement bien
il se débrouille en fait c'est pas mal
est ce que tu veux faire un petit match
devant les téléspectateurs oui plaisir
avec les enfants gagnant c'est parti
quad il est au micro de chérie c'est
parti si tu perds bien entendu delphine
perd son cachet aujourd'hui et si tu
gagnes
j'offrirai un resto à tous les
chroniqueurs et à toi également trois
points derrière
rappelez moi de cacher de delphine sur
wii 2 0 merci mon projet a laissé bien
là à lire à la tire il
voilà c'est pas toi ça c'est pas toi
sarti on m'a dit oui à tous de bien que
deux points d'écart mais thébaux sert il
reprends toi
ouais voilà assez mou de alors une rage
ou bien ils nous rêvons une chose 39 2
points des talents le talent des
pouilles
là c'est vraiment beau rouge et on se
revoit pas bon a comme toujours comme il
joue pas très bien roger crochète ont
défoncé
je me croise l atonie posé je te dis que
tu le tape c'est sûr elle sait pas gérer
savez castaldi on est les meilleurs
d'entre vous qui arrivez à ses quatre
points d'avancé vrai c'est vrai j'ai
oublié de taxes à l élevage et l'oubli
ces prêts auront fait le paris d'hier
qui te 12 mois qui devraient délit qui
tombait raide et démarrer dès mes frères
ta rien à voir tout ce monde là et c'est
comme ça que oui
s'il vous plaît les frères lumière de
castaldi merci à tous de travail